you went on carson the first time um
you did your act i don't know how many
minutes carson gave you like
six minutes you did it two you performed
it two hundred times maybe a hundred a
hundred times oh yeah that's a lot of
times still a lot right and when you
finally got on carson which was the goal
of every single comedian
were you nervous i mean were you just
like just out of your mind out of your
mind nervous how do you mind so how do
you get through that and did you think
you did a decent performance the first
time you wrote i was okay i wasn't that
happy with it was your rhythm off was
your timing off was that the problem i
was so i had never been in front of 500
people before
just the studio audience i'd never seen
an audience that big how did they find
you to put you on there at the improv in
l.a
and and how many years have you been
toiling away before they did you know
what howard i didn't toil too hard it
was four years i started in 76 i was on
tonight's show in um
in 81. and johnny does he did to give
you the the i always thought the
comedian should hate johnny because
johnny would sit there no other guest
went through this but johnny would watch
you do your performance and then if he
deemed it so worthy he brought you over
to the couch
first the first level is this the okay
you get the okay right which is i i got
that and that was still the greatest
moment of my life right and then four or
five shows later then they let you on
the couch did you ever hang with johnny
personally yes i did and and was that
comfortable for you or was he just too
iconic and too important to have a good
time too iconic and too important to
really relax right but
it was me and gary shandling at johnny's
house we went to dinner this is after he
was off the show right and i said to
gary one day i saw gary and i said you
know why don't we call johnny
we said you know one of these days we're
going to pick up the paper and he's
going to be gone it's going to be gone
let's just do it what's the worst he
could wow and he he made both our lives
let's call him and now gary being gary
shandling and i know him a little bit
he must have been like we can't call no
no
you know no he was he was totally into
it we did it
we went out where'd you go we went to
this fish place up in malibu i don't
know what it was some tiny little fish
restaurant was he sick or anything no no
he was he was in he was in in very good
spirits and good health and was there
stuff to talk about yeah you know we
talked here's one thing i remember he
was talking johnny was talking about how
show business is so crazy and so
unpredictable he said when we heard
lawrence welk was getting a tv show it
was the biggest joke
people were pounding the table they're
giving lawrence welk a tv show right he
can't even talk english right and of
course it's the greatest the biggest hit
in history of television and by the way
lawrence welk even defeated sid caesar
and that and mel brooks and all those
guys were writing sid caesar came back
with the second show he went up against
um i saw this on the mel brooks tribute
oh really he went up against lawrence
welk and got the he got his his he got
beaten in the he got killed that was it
the end of caesar lawrence wilke yeah so
that was his
example of don't ever think you know
what's going to happen in this business